[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin et à
distance dans sa belle région normande
bonjour hervé morin merci beaucoup merci
d'être avec nous président de la région
normandie président du mouvement les
centristes on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentait ce matin par
pascal janer du groupe ebra bon jean
pascal
on va commencer bien sûr par cette
allocution en d'emmanuel macron hier
hervé morin qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé de cette intervention
goûter si je résume les choses je trouve
que l'autosatisfaction du chef de l'état
sur la gestion de la crise
quand on a en tête l'absence
d'anticipation sur un ensemble de sujets
majeurs qui ont probablement amené la
france à a confiné très sévèrement et à
reprendre plus tard que les autres avec
ses conséquences aujourd'hui sur
l'activité économique puisque nous
sommes un des pays européens est telle
qu'elle l'a l'activité économique a le
plus fait bly cette autosatisfaction
probablement été mal venu sur le reste
je trouve complètement ce qu'il a pu
dire sur sur le soutien à la police
nationale sur les manifestations anti
raciste je pense que on est pas on doit
apporter son soutien le plus total à une
police nationale qui n'est pas raciste
qui ne doit pas faire l'objet d'une
espèce de suspicion généralisée il y
avait il à trouver les bombes on sait
que le sujet était compliqué il était
attendu il a trouvé les bons mots
là-dessus pour vous et oui pour moi un
pour moi il a trouvé les bons mots
restent après à savoir comment tout ça
sera déclinée mais il fallait le faire
voyez bien ces manifestations tous les
soirs policiers ont appris ce matin que
la bac police 6,6 s'il en est une qui
est en permanence au contact de la
délinquance à mener sur et la sécurité
des pays de nos compatriotes tous les
jours à manifester au pied de l'arc de
triomphe ce week end au co
on voit bien qu'il est il était temps de
d'éteindre le feu oui le président
parlait de séparatisme vous trouvez ce
risque réel ce mot approprié
je trouve que notre pays depuis
malheureusement bientôt deux ans vit et
face à une menace de deux importantes
liées à l'absence de de cohésion
d'unités on a eu le mouvement des gilet
jaune puis les manifestations massives
sur les retraites dont ce depuis deux
ans le pays souffre de deux voilà de
fragmentation importante et je crois
qu'il est important que le prix en mains
république refixe le cadre je crois que
c'était absolument essentiel la question
c'est pas simplement celle de qui sont
évoqués tous les jours sur le racisme
l'antisémitisme
il ya aussi des questions centrales qui
peuvent être posées qui est celle de
l'égalité des chances parce que derrière
tout cela il ya un sujet majeur qui
empêche notre pays probablement d'aller
vers plus d'unité plus de cohésion c'est
la question d'égalité des chances que
des enfants issus de milieux modestes
quelle que soit leur couleur de peau
puisse autant que les autres accéder à
l'école à l'université aux grandes
écoles et on sait très bien à quel point
ça n'est pas le cas en france je pense
que c'est ce sujet là qui doit être au
coeur de nos préoccupations des
prochains mois il ya un débat qui a été
relancée ce week-end par la porte parole
du gouvernement s'il est en deuil c'est
suis sur les statistiques ethniques est
ce que vous êtes favorable vous êtes un
sujet sur lequel j'ai beaucoup travaillé
en son temps et donc en effet derrière
la question des statistiques ethniques
c'est comment lutter contre les
discriminations
est-ce que c'est par des mesures de
discrimination positive
j'ai été à l'origine savez probablement
pas quand j'étais président du groupe
parlementaire de l'udep de du cv anonyme
comment faire en sorte qu'un jeune dont
le nom rappelle l'afrique peut avoir
autant de chance d'avoir
un entretien d'embauché que quand vous
appelez dupont ou durand et vous savez
très bien que les études universitaires
ont été menées là-dessus des mondes qui
a un rapport de 1 à 3 voire de 20,4 et
donc je reviens en sujet d'avancé que le
sujet d'abord c'est celui de l'égalité
des chances parce que ceux qui se posent
pour les enfants des quartiers
populaires des quartiers en difficulté
se pose aussi pour les enfants des zones
rurales se pose aussi pour les enfants
d'ouvriers et d'employés
donc je pense qu'il faut l'aborder plus
massivement ce qu'il faut aussi mais ça
veut dire que les statistiques ethniques
c'est une bonne chose ou pas les
statistiques ethniques en tant que tels
si cela permet éventuellement ensuite de
pouvoir porter le point sur des
discriminations à l'embauché ou des
sujets de ce genre ça doit être regardée
mais il faut le mesurer avec beaucoup de
prudence parce que cela n'obère pas le
sujet central qui est celui d'abord de
l'égalité des chances
s'il permet ensuite de pouvoir faire ce
que font d'ailleurs très bien les états
unis d'obliger les entreprises à avoir
des politiques de recrutement qui évite
toute discrimination à leur gauche ça
doit être regardée enlever le mot race
de la constitution comme le propose
julien de normandie là vous êtes
favorable j'ai pas encore vu vos pieds
c'est julien normandie le ministre qui
propose d'enlever le mot race de la
constitution est-ce que là pour vous est
une bonne chose parce qu'il faut d'abord
et avant tout éviter de vouloir toucher
la constitution tous les jours c'est
c'est un contrat social la constitution
et donc ne bougeons pas la constitution
à chaque fois qu'il y à des
manifestations ou qui sont des
manifestations de quelques dizaines de
milliers de personnes pensent qu'il faut
c'est éviter de créer des débats au sein
du pays qui risquent de fragmenter
encore un peu plus la france allez on va
parler du déconfinement pascal oui alors
le retour à la quasi normal le retour de
tous les enfants l'école le 22 juin
c'est une bonne chose oui c'est une
bonne chose et leur ont la compagne
de l'idée d'obligations on avait une
incohérence c'est à dire qu'on disait il
faut que les enfants notamment des plus
décrocheurs reviennent à l'école ou au
collège et en même temps l'école n'était
ou l'instruction n'était pas obligatoire
ce qui était une première depuis jules
ferry et donc dès lors que le chef de
l'état évoque la question de
l'obligation que des enfants de l'école
primaire ou du collège puisse revenir et
tous revenir à partir de la semaine
prochaine pourquoi pas
on profite pour dire qu'il ya tout ça va
être plus du symbole notamment pour les
collégiens puisque on nous annonçait la
fin du collège pour le 26 juin gauckler
ils vont revenir le lundi pour revoir
leurs professeurs pendant quelques jours
mais que pendant dizaine de jours les
enfants du primaire puisse se retrouver
au leurs professeurs reprendre certains
fondamentaux j'ai deux enfants en bas
âge je vois qu'on en parle ça me paraît
pas une mauvaise idée
hervé morin emmanuel macron a parlé des
écoles a parlé des collèges il n'a pas
parlé des lycées qui sont gérés par les
régions est ce que vous y voyez plus
clair sur ce qu'il va se passer dans les
lycées où il va se faire ce que je
disais qu'il allait se faire c'est à
dire qu clair on ouvre les lycées en
fonction des besoins avérés spécifique
l'aller première année de prépa là des
gestes dont on estime qu'ils doivent
être et a pris par des lycéens dans les
lycées professionnels la l'ouverture
d'un lycée pour permettre des examens
des concours mais il était évident que
dès lors que les conseils de classe sont
était passé rouvrir complètement
totalement est pleinement les lycées là
où il n'y a pas de problème de garde
puisque les lycéens se gardent tout seul
ça me paraissait inutiles et donc au
bout du compte on finit par faire ce que
j'avais dit qu'on ferait le président a
parlé de travailler plus
or là on concerne davantage l'activité
comment vous l'avez entendu ça veut dire
encore érodé les 35 heures travailler
plus longtemps sur la carrière donc
rallonger l'âge de départ à la retraite
ou alors créer nous emploi comment vous
l'avez perçu cette formule bah écoutez
je
j'ai cherché quand on parle de
travailler plus en général on évoque la
question des 35 heures mais je je je
profite pour dire que d'abord c'est de
faire en sorte que nos compatriotes qui
reprennent qui sont aujourd'hui salarié
puisse reprendre le boulot et
deuxièmement c'est ne pas oublier que à
partir du mois de septembre on nous
annonce des plans sociaux absolument
considérable dans les tas de secteurs et
que c'est probablement le sujet et
travailler plus c'est d'abord faire en
sorte qu'on puisse limiter au maximum
les dégâts avant de créer des débats
jeudi parce que pour moi c'est une
préoccupation majeure
avant de créer des débats dont on voit
bien qu'il risque de fracture et
fragmenté le pays un peu plus et que le
pays est aujourd'hui très fragile sa
cohésion c'est ce débat sur le temps de
travail qui risque de fracture et le
pays pour vous oui peut me vois très
bien que les organisations syndicales
vont y être opposés et donc je suis pas
convaincu que le premier sujet soit soit
celui ci donc pour vous travailler
davantage ça ne doit pas être augmenté
la durée d'une de travail du temps trail
et dieu sait que j'ai défendu cette idée
mais je pense que c'est pas le moment
approprié
je pense que ce sens du débat qu'on peut
avoir en 18 mois il y aura une élection
présidentielle qu'on peut avoir au
moment d'une élection présidentielle
mais créer une nouvelle fragmentation
c'est prendre un risque important dans
cette période sur la politique de
l'emploi emmanuel macron qui a dit tout
a été mis en oeuvre par le gouvernement
pour sauvegarder nos emplois c'est
inédit et je veux ce soir que vous le
mesurier pleinement il a raison là
dessus à moi je trouve que le boulot qui
a été fait par bruno le maire pour le
soutien à l'économie
mérite d'être saluée il n'y a pas de
doute là dessus les régions ont fait
beaucoup de choses aussi complémentaires
à l'état nous allons faire d'autres
il reste des sujets qui peuvent être
traités qui est notamment la question
des fonds propres des entreprises
puisque il faut améliorer leurs hôtes
bilan pour leur permettre d'investir le
moment venu puisque après la crise
viendra le temps où il faudra relancer
l'activité et la question du haut de
bilan se posera donc il ya des sujets
qui méritent d'être encore traités il ya
le soutien au secteur du tourisme dont
on voit bien qu'ils ne se doit pas se
limiter à l'année 2020 puisque le plus
compliqué sera probablement l'année 2021
puisqu'il y aura la période d'hiver à
passer mais disons les choses il y a eu
beaucoup de volontarisme et souvent des
choses plutôt bien fait
un mot sur le tourisme un mot sur le
tourisme puisque vous vous en parler les
vacances des français se feront
probablement en france beaucoup plus que
d'habitude est ce que d'après ce que
vous constatez dans votre région ça va
profiter à la normandie cd je l'espère
je pense que les mois de juillet et
d'août ce rebond on a des locations de
maisons comme jamais on n'a eu on a un
élan alors qui n'est pas du même manque
mais qui est intéressant qui est une
très forte demande immobilière de
franciliens qui toute évidence on tombe
vite quitté paris pour rejoindre
d'autres contrées avec une qualité de
vie incomparable à celle qu'on peut
avoir en ile de france
donc il y aura probablement en juillet
de tisserand bomble il ya un vrai un
vrai frémissement dans les réservations
je vous lis le sujet c'est pas c'est pas
cet été le sujet c'est après alors nous
on va essayer de mettre en place avec
les acteurs du tourisme toute une série
de mesures pour l'automne pour faire en
sorte qu'il puisse y avoir des
manifestations les gens viennent
nombreux à des périodes où c'est ça
devient plus compliqué à un mot sur
puisque le pdg de la sncf monsieur
farandou disais hier dans le journal du
dimanche qui travaillait avec les
régions justement pour faciliter les
déplacements entre régions est ce que
vous président de région vous travailler
là dessus
écuyer avec la sncf vous savez nous on
est on est des grands malheureux sur le
ferroviaire en servir lamentable qui
marche très mal avec des trains qui sont
à bout de souffle la région acheté plus
d'un milliard de train pour essayer
d'améliorer les choses ont fait 500
millions d'euros de travaux donc nous
d'abord on voudrait des trains qui
arrivent à l'heure et qui marche
donc j'ai un monsieur farandou fait en
sorte que les trains intercités et les
trains du quotidien fonctionne beaucoup
mieux qu'il ne fonctionne aujourd'hui
nous région normandie on a pris le
taureau par les cornes puisqu'on a pris
là la totalité de la compétence sur le
réseau ferroviaire on investit on a un
plan marshall gigantesque espérons qu'il
donnera des fruits à partir de la fin de
l'année puisque le matériel ferroviaire
à y voir mais le sujet contre près qu'on
toutes les régions de france c'est que
ça marche
et malheureusement ça marche souvent
très mal puisqu'on parlait d'économie
vous le disais lors de la relance a
sonné ce que les régions les moyens de
leur relance la question qu'a posée le
chef de l'état à travers la
décentralisation des libertés locales la
participation derrière tout ça c'est la
question de la démocratie c'est en clair
faire en sorte que nos compatriotes
soient associés à la décision publique
ce que les collectivités locales font
tous les jours on va revenir là-dessus
hervé morin mais sur le plan financier
sur le plan financier du j'y viens j'y
viens on sait que les invités ont été
fortement impactés par cette crise
sanitaire est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
problème de moyens ce que vous demandez
à l'état d'aider financièrement plus que
tout est déjà paru donc je dis tous ces
maux liés à aux libertés locales et aux
et à la décentralisation doivent être
accompagnés très clairement d'un plan de
stabilisation des finances locales
les régions qui pour l'instant ont été
complètement oubliés par l'état comme si
on nous reprochait d'exister sont devant
seront dans des situations financières
absolument dramatique
mais ce sentiment emmanuel macron vous
repreniez le gouvernement vous reproche
d'exister vous êtes oublié écoutez moi
je constate c'est qu'on discute avec les
communes on discute avec les
départements mais pas
les régions je pense que les régions
plutôt fait le job est d'ailleurs qu'on
vous a vu un sondage quelques semaines
dans un 2 1 des dans le jdd je crois
très clairement nos compatriotes
appelait à plus d'autonomie locale et
libertés locales est pas vraiment un
renforcement des moyens de l'état parce
que tout le monde a constaté la
paralysie de l'état lors de cette crise
allait justement vous parlez
décentralisation va ré écouter ce que
disait hier emmanuel macron à ce sujet
il s'est exprimé là dessus sans
toutefois prononcer le mot de
décentralisation mais on nous vend à
porte à plus de responsabilité pour les
élus locaux on écoute tout ne peut pas
être décidé si souvent à paris face à
l'épidémie
les citoyens les entreprises les
syndicats les associations les
collectivités locales les agents de
l'état dans les territoires ont su faire
preuve d'ingéniosité d'efficacité de
solidarité faisons-leur davantage
confiance libérons la créativité et
l'énergie du terrain c'est pourquoi je
veux ouvrir pour notre pays une page
nouvelle donnant des libertés et des
responsabilités inédite à ceux qui
agissent au plus près de nos vies
liberté responsabilité pour nos hôpitaux
nos universités nos entrepreneurs nos
mères et beaucoup d'autres acteurs
essentiels
vous êtes optimiste quand vous entendez
ça hervé morin sur l'avenir de la
décentralisation ajouté le chef de
l'état l'a écrit dans un livre qu'il a
appelée révolution
lerhe lui l'été dernier donc ils avaient
les mêmes mots rien ne s'est passé
il l'a expliqué quand il a été là au
contraire centralisée avec un poil la
technocratie sans précédent il l'a
évoqué au lendemain du débat sur les
gilets jaunes souvenez vous ces
rencontres avec les maires ou eux mêmes
sujets ont été évoqués
rien ne s'est passé donc permettez moi
d'avoir un doute si enfin le prix en
mains république fait ce que d'ailleurs
font tous les autres pays européens
c'est-à-dire très largement confié aux
collectivités locales et politique de
proximité d'une part pour les rendre
plus efficaces
surtout jeudi par un besoin de
démocratie quand quand je construis la
politique agricole de la région je la
construis avec le monde agricole
quand je construis la politique
économique de la raison je la construis
avec le monde économique et je peux le
faire sur tous les sujets ainsi et ça y
est nous qui pouvons le faire c'est donc
un facteur de de participation de co
construction des politiques demande
tellement nos compatriotes on voit bien
que le système représentatif a ses
limites
aujourd'hui est qu'il faut des moyens
complémentaires qui sont celles de de la
construction partagée de politique pour
inventer innover pour bâtir des modèles
expérimentaux
tout ça n'est possible que dans un
dialogue permanent avec la collective et
moi tous les jours
j'ai des gens qui m'écrivent qui
m'envoient des mails qui me disait un
truc qui marche pas tout ça moi je peux
le faire parce que tout en étant
président d'une région déjà plus éloigné
que le maire j'ai derrière moi une
administration qui est capable de réagir
au quart de tour de prendre son
téléphone un bureau de l'administration
centrale vous l'avez jamais au téléphone
comment vous la voyez cette nouvelle
étape de décentralisation ce mot n'a pas
été prononcé on a déjà eu beaucoup de
délégations de compétence transport
incompétence que peut-on faire de plus
on va faire beaucoup plus beaucoup
beaucoup plus je pense qu'il faut enfin
bâtir un modèle simple j'ai essayé de
lui exprimer un des mots compréhensibles
par tout le monde
le pr mettre en oeuvre le principe de
subsidiarité c'est à dire bâtir un
modèle non pauleta condescend a confié
quelques compétences supplémentaires aux
collectivités mais au contraire pour
chaque pouvoir chaque compétence se dire
on le confie à l'échelon le plus proche
et on ne confie un échelon plus éloignée
des citoyens que lorsqu'on voit bien que
c'est le seul moyen de le rendre
efficace
ça doit être ça la régionalisation et
les libertés locales auxquelles nous
appelons c'est se dire on ne confie à
l'état que ce qui peut être assuré par
qui doit être assuré par l'état il ya
des choses est vide
un joli suspense la politique étrangère
la justice tout ça ça fait pas tout mais
ensuite pour chaque autre pouvoir se
dire où est il le mieux exercer pour
rendre vivant que la démocratie
française et rendre le système efficace
hervé morin les régionales sont prévues
en tout cas l'année prochaine elle selon
le journal du dimanche emmanuel macron
pourrait envisager de les reporter après
la présidentielle
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette idée
d'écouter voilà d'abord il faut que ça
soit fondée on peut pas changer les
dates des gens nous a réduit c'est
justement pour laisser le temps de mener
à bien cette étape de décentralisation
selon journée du dimanche est ce que là
ça serait fondée à ce que là vous y
seriez favorable si c'est un vrai
travail conduisant un texte pas
simplement à des déclarations pas
suivies d'effet s'il y a un grand champ
team en chantier avec une réorganisation
complète de des pouvoirs publics parce
que ça concerne bien sûr les
collectivités locales mais ça concerne
aussi les cas qui a fait des préfets des
rois nu la plupart du temps leur
enlevant des champs de compétences qui
sont aujourd'hui exercées par
l'administration centrale et qui
pourrait être exercée par les
administrations déconcentrées de l'état
par les services de l'état dans les
territoires
donc s'il ya ces chantiers la très
ouvert avec une vraie volonté d'aboutir
rapidement ça peut se discuter mais donc
ça veut dire que vous n'êtes pas opposés
à un report des régionales d'un an voire
plus j'ai je suis pas fermé par nature
donc je ne veux pas fermer la porte tout
de suite mais cela imposerait une vraie
démarche sincère et rapide de
construction d'une nouvelle organisation
des pouvoirs publics pas simplement de
quelques toilettage qui ferait que pour
des raisons politiques on reporte les
élections régionales ou départementales
selon le journal du dimanche des
présidents de région ont été consultées
vous avez été consultés vous sur ce
sujet écoutez la consultation était très
réduite je pense que nous avons mais le
chêne de ces cas-là de l'état
cette idée avec vous non renaud muselier
je crois voit le chef de l'état ce midi
le président de région de france mais
mais sinon personne n'a été consulté pas
ma connaissance et vous en avez ceinture
noire fois que vous en avez parlé entre
présidents de région vous en avait parlé
avec renaud muselier notamment à évoquer
sa entre nos ouailles officiel de
régions de france là dessus puisque
renaud muselier rencontre le chef de
l'état aujourd'hui vous le disais
d'abord attendons de savoir ce que veut
l'état et après on prendra position
merci beaucoup